bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7-8
bienvenue pour ce début de semaine si
comme nous vous étiez un repos hier pour
ce week end de pâques nous allons une
nouvelle fois faire le tour de
l'actualité locale au cours de la
prochaine heure avec nos invités à
commencer par catherine dupont le calvez
daniel kokal bonsoir à toutes les deux
vous êtes membre d'autisme en yvelines
c'est aujourd'hui la journée mondiale de
l'autisme un nouveau plan va être
présentée par le gouvernement vous nous
direz s'ils répondent ou non à vos
attentes on découvre eu pour l'instant
les titres de ce soir en images les
reportages à suivre au cours de cette
édition les rythmes scolaires tout
d'abord elle est commune avait jusqu'à
la fin du mois de mars pour se décider
le changement dès ce mois de septembre
ou dans un an et demi à saint quentin en
yvelines
les villes ont fait le choix d'attendre
2014 à l'exception de trappes éducation
toujours la carte scolaire 2013 qui se
dessine dans le département de 800
élèves supplémentaires sont attendus à
la rentrée scolaire 66 ouvertures de
classes programmées 49 fermeture le
point sur notre secteur
ce mardi soir match au sommet pour le
quart de finale de la ligue des
champions entre le psg et barcelone et
dernier entraînement depuis le camp des
loges à saint-germain-en-laye pour les
joueurs parisiens
le club de basket de guyancourt a reçu
pour la quatrième fois le label école
française de mini-basket un label
décerné pour trois ans qui mise sur la
formation l'encadrement sur les 4450 six
clubs affiliés au niveau français le
club de basket de guyancourt et le 24e à
se voir remettre cette distinction
et puis environnement également ce soir
la chronique de julie rocha soit reste
en moins d'une demi-heure bonsoir jul et
bonsoir également anthony puisque ce
soir la chronique environnement sera à
la fois écolo et sportives
de l'opération balle jaune actions
phares de la fédération française de
tennis en matière de développement
durable
nous recevrons pour cela stéphane feugas
directeur de la ligue des yvelines de
tennis et véronique moreau vice
présidente en charge des actions
sociales et solidaires qui participent à
cette action
voilà pourquoi anthony vous serez aussi
avec nous au cours de la chronique
environnement pour évoquer cet aspect
sportif du tennis dans le département et
puis il sera aussi question de sport
tout à l'heure avec elle du baseball les
cougars de montigné l'entraîneur va nous
rejoindre sur le plateau oui je
recevrais arnaud faux l'entraîneur de
l'équipe fanion de montigny des cougars
pour évoquer les ambitions du club mini
montain avant le début de la nouvelle
saison de division 2 et puis nous
parlerons aussi de la 33e édition de la
course du printemps et puis comme
d'habitude
évidemment tous les résultats du
week-end avec un pronostic pour ce match
ce qui va poser paris à barcelone si
vous nous suivez en direct il est 18
heures c'est dans 2h 2h30 à peu près que
pour le coup d'envoi pour le moment
c'est d'éducation dont il est question
verdict pour ses parents qui attendent
les nouveaux rythmes scolaires 2013 ou
2014 tour d'horizon avec ce reportage de
la rédaction
alors rentrée 2013 ou 2014
les communes ont arrêté leur décision
pour la mise en place de la réforme des
rythmes scolaires à saint quentin en
yvelines
une seule commune a choisi septembre
2013 il s'agit de trappes les autres
communes ont opté pour 2014 comme
montigny le bretonneux pour trois
principales raisons 1 déjà la circulaire
est sorti très tard ça c'est la première
chose parce que jusqu'à présent tout le
monde en a beaucoup parlé mais personne
ne savait ce qu'il y avait dans la
circulaire de la circulaire on n'est pas
assez précises dans les engagements des
uns et des autres 3 la ville de montigny
a déjà voté son budget pour l'année 2013
en décembre 2012
le coût de la réforme pour les finances
communales est estimée à plus d'un
million d'euros
après concertation avec des directeurs
d'école des représentants de fédérations
de parents d'élèves et des responsables
d'associations de la ville
des points sont à anticiper selon le
maire comme le planning des agents
techniques communaux pour la journée du
mercredi
en plus de la réorganisation des
activités sportives et culturelles des
enfants
le syndicat et ses nuits ppa pelle à une
nouvelle manifestation nationale pour
l'éducation
samedi 6
il apparaît journée mondiale de
l'autisme en ce 2 avril pour en parler
alors que le gouvernement français doit
lancer un nouveau plan d'action à
l'association autisme yvelines bonsoir
donc à catherine dupont le calvez pardon
et daniel sont qu'à vous êtes
respectivement administratrice de cette
association et chef du service
d'éducation spécialisée et de soins à
domicile qui est piloté donc par autisme
yvelines on va entrer tout de suite dans
le vif du sujet avec ce nouveau plan qui
doit être présenté pour la période 2013
le changement qui semble s'amorcer elle
sait que la prise en compte l' approche
sera plutôt comportementale et
éducatives plutôt que psychanalytique ce
qui avait été le cas jusqu'à présent
qu'est-ce que ça va changer ce
changement d'approché force a changé que
ça fait comme plus de vingt ans que les
approches éducatives sont mis en place
dans beaucoup d'établissements en france
trop peu en fait là c'est la
reconnaissance en fait de l'efficacité
de ces approches pour pour pouvoir
éduquer les enfants avec autisme avec
succès et leur ouvrir aussi un avenir
ça va changer vraiment là la façon dont
on va leur parler dont on va s'adresser
à eux dont on va les accompagner au
quotidien c'est ça ça va donc évoluer
sur ce plan là ce plan qui semble
véritablement attendu je vais citer la
présidente d'autisme france elle dit que
la france a 40 ans de retard que le
chantier phénoménal
est ce que vous partagez ce point de vue
oui complètement comme c'était complique
à ce retard 40 ans de rotin est ce qui
explique ces la prise en charge
psychanalytique qui est encore beaucoup
trop présente en france et il est
vraiment temps qu'on qu'on arrive à
d'éducatif avec des ânes accueil et une
prise en compte de la personne
éducative en fait il faut qu'on tienne
compte de l'enfant qu'il est con et des
cookies et des évaluations et puis qu'on
ait recours à des approches validées
scientifiquement puisqu'en fait la haute
autorité de la santé a reconnu les
approches éducatives l'an dernier et
maintenant il faut les appliquer le
problème en france il est là encore
c'est qu'il ya des recommandations de
bonne pratique mais qui ne sont pas
appliquées partout
donc il est vraiment temps que ce soit
fait et on verra comment ça va évoluer
dans les prochains mois avec ce plan du
gouvernement qui devrait être présenté
prochainement journée mondiale de
l'autisme
aujourd'hui la question du jour la
question que nous sommes allez vous
poser est quel regard portez-vous sur
cette question de l'autisme justement
vos réponses je pense qu'il faut mettre
tout en oeuvre pour aider les malades de
nautisme que je pense que c'est une
maladie qui touche pas mal de français
pas mal de personnes au monde il faut
intégrer les autistes avec des gens qui
ne sont pas s'alarmer peut-être de
s'ouvrir comme ça au monde et découvrir
autre chose que leur bulle
surtout pour les parents un enfant qui
est renfermé sur lui même et tout ça
c'est ça pose problème et qu'il faudrait
quand même travailler avec eux et puis
on donne une chance de vivre comme les
autres comme nous quoi et je trouve que
les médias n'en parlent pas assez il
faudrait que ça change pas difficile
quand on a un enfant autiste je suppose
pouvoir l'élever dans deux des
conditions dignes
je pense qu'il est seulement de beaucoup
d'efforts ça demande beaucoup d'efforts
de pouvoir effectivement les intégrer
que parce que il n'ya pas ces
établissements peut-être pour ces
enfants là
enfin où ces jeunes et que en on doit
faire beaucoup
parce que pour les parents je pense que
c'est très difficile à vivre
intégrer les enfants autistes à ceux qui
ne le sont pas c'est l'une des réactions
qu'on a entendues dans le micro trottoir
c'est une bonne piste
oui puis sur c'est ce qu'il faut c'est
on espère que le plan ira dans ce sens
un plan qui malheureusement devaient
être annoncés ce soir et qu'il ne sera
pas et on attend désespérément puisque
ça fait plusieurs fois qu'il reportait
donc là on finit par être inquiet dans
le milieu associatif
le plan qui va couvrir la période 2013
2017 c'est le troisième plan du
gouvernement il y en a eu auparavant
pour la période 2008 2012 quel bilan
vous en faites pas ce que ça a été un
blanc qui a permis de réaliser quelques
avancées alors quelques avancées mais en
fait trop peu en termes de de mise en
place de dispositifs
donc il ya des sa part est une goutte
d'eau en fait il ya à peu près je suis
pas trop les chiffres mais voilà ça
concerne 400 personnes avec autisme
alors que des milliers de personnes
chaque année il ya des milliers
d'enfants qui sont diagnostiqués et
suite au diagnostic qu'on leur propose
très peu de prise en charge et pour les
parents ça reste vraiment parcours du
combattant
et voilà j'espère qu'avec la
clarification de la prise en charge la
personne autiste ça sera beaucoup plus
facile pour les familles et que pour a
inventé un dispositif en fait due depuis
le diagnostic jusqu'à l'âge adulte
puisque vous avez évoqué quelques
chiffres on va continuer sur cette sur
cette lancée tout d'abord celui ci est
notre chiffre du jour d'ailleurs 480000
c'est le nombre d'autistes en france
soit une personne sur 150 cela monte à
600 mille personnes autistes en france
si on inclut toutes les personnes qui
sont concernées dont celles à haut
niveau de fonctionnement en france
quelques cent mille jeunes de moins de
20 ans sont atteints par l'autisme est
la principale demande des parents
effectivement c'est la scolarisation
aujourd'hui est ce qu'il est possible de
scolariser un enfant son enfant
lorsqu'il est atteint d'autisme
c'est très compliqué puisque on est
confronté à beaucoup de refus et surtout
un manque de moyens c'est à dire qu'il
faut se mettre aussi à la place de
l'enseignante qui a trente élèves dans
sa classe et qui on ne donne pas de
formation ou de moyens
donc le souci il est que la société
donne des moyens de formation il ya
aussi des avs des auxiliaires de vie
scolaire et justement doit autisme en iv
nous avons développé un service le
sessad que dont daniel coca les chefs de
service et nous avons formé des ape
accompagnement psycho éducatif qui
accompagnent les enfants à l'école mais
j'ai laissé damian faisait justement
vous allez me présente des patates sa
structure en quoi elle consiste service
d'éducation spéciale et de prendre un
domicile alors le domicile étant entendu
que ce sont les lieux de vie de l'enfant
donc au niveau du sessad autisme en
dividendes intervenons beaucoup dans les
milieux scolaires en fait et dont sur
deux services donc un service sur des
accompagnements individuels ou là les
enfants sont accompagnés donc par des
ape à sachant que ce service là restent
à la charge en partie des familles et le
sessad vous accompagne en plus des
enfants qui sont scolarisés sur des
dispositifs spéciaux comme des classes
spécialisées donc les clis pour le
primaire et les ulis les unités locales
pour l'inclusion scolaire au niveau des
collèges
nous accompagnons pas encore il ya
quelques dispositifs au niveau de la
formation professionnelle mais pour
l'instant on n'a pas encore de jeunes
dans cet espace
combien de jeunes justement dans le
département alors nous on a un agrément
pour 56 jeunes enfants mais pas le
financement pour ses 56 personnes quoi
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui pouvait
matériellement grâce à laure
matériellement officiellement nous
pouvons entrants
accompagné 36 enfants et adolescents
dans les fers dans la compagne 56 en
fait c'est très très peu finalement 56
imagine donc pour votre place et donc
comment vous faites alors pour ce manque
de financement ce sont les dons la zone
euro non non non non non il faut trouver
de l'argent donc à une partie josé dit
le s agit donc c'est une vingtaine
d'enfants qui sont dans les
accompagnants en fait sont pris en
charge par les familles c'est
insuffisant par rapport aux 6 peut-être
aux demandes parce que 50 cinéma me 36
si on sent base et ce n'est pas juste
sur l'éléphant dont vous deviez disposés
en réalité combien de demandes vous
pouvez avoir à peu près ses deux mandats
parent en fait on a autant de demandes
que de places finalement à peu près
smoothies sachant qu'elle y est mieux
donc l'institut médico éducatif qui
accueille aussi deux jeunes enfants il y
à 82 personnes en liste d'attenté 82
enfants en liste d'attenté
là on parle des plus jeunes on parle des
enfants peut peut-être intéressé
d'ailleurs à la question du dépistage
parce que le dépistage là aussi c'est un
point compliqué c'est à dire c'est dans
le dossier de presse un d'autisme
yvelines votre association un médecin
sur trois ne sait pas ce qu'est
l'autisme
c'est inquiétant c'est très inquiétant
c'est malheureusement la réalité et
c'est aussi une demande et une attente
des associations pour le plan on
souhaiterait que les médecins et plus de
formations puisque les médecins qui ne
sont pas formés ils ont trois heures de
cours dans leur cursus universitaire sur
l'autisme
donc les médecins ne peuvent pas
détecter donc ne peuvent pas diriger les
familles vers des spécialistes et le
handicap prend prend de l'ampleur
or si on arrivait à détecter les enfants
dès l'âge de 18 mois
je dis bien détecté parce que le
diagnostic arrive quelquefois plus tard
mais à 18 mois on peut vraiment faire du
dépistage et si on arrive à faire du
dépistage à l'âge de 18 mois
il ya dirigé les parents vers les
centres de diagnostic et bien on devrait
pouvoir diagnostiquer les enfants à
l'âge de 3 ans et même avoir une prise
en charge avant même le diagnostic ce
qui signifierait que ont il n'y aurait
pas de sur handicap voyez toutes les
conséquences qui sont dues à la non
prise en compte de la personne dans son
fonctionnement
on sait aujourd'hui que beaucoup de
personnes sont très lourdement handicapé
parce qu'elles n'ont pas reçu à temps
l'éducation spécifiques dont elle avait
besoin et c'est dramatique entre autres
chez les adultes et on voit énormément
d'adultes qui sont dans des hôpitaux
psychiatriques qui ne sont pas adaptés
et c'est catastrophique c'est on peut le
dire
inhumain certains sont dans des chambres
sans matelas dans des pièces on a même
du mal à appeler des chambres
certains sont venus certains n'arrivent
pas à porter de vêtements il se passe
des choses dramatiques en france nous
les familles nous attendons vraiment que
l'état fasse un effort et qu'on réalise
le drame de l'autize en france on arrive
à une personne sur 150 si on retient le
chiffre officiel de 480 milles ça fait
un sur cent si on prend les 600000 qui
inclut tous les profils même les plus
légers donc il faut vraiment considérer
ce chiffre c'est que quelque chose de
très important c'est comment vous
expliquer justement que les pouvoirs
publics ne réalise pas ce chiffre parce
que effectivement parler aussi des
enfants des structures dans le fond mais
derrière mais les 600000 que vous
évoquiez il ya aussi les adultes est là
aussi pour s'en occuper qui voilà tout
simplement qui s'en occupe comment s'en
occuper
comment les prendre en charge comment
vous expliquez que le gouvernement les
pouvoirs publics ne réalise pas
finalement et que même le plan qui
d'ailleurs devaient être présentées vous
l'avez rappelé aujourd'hui ne soit
toujours pas présenté il ya des
problèmes de mesure de financement et
d'arbitrage ça ce sont les nouvelles que
j'ai eues auparavant au ministère on
n'arrive pas à se mettre d'accord
nous subissons l'influencent
psychanalytique depuis 40 ans aucun
enfant autiste n'ira mieux parce qu'on
va le séparait de sa mère ou enfin parce
qu'on va guérir la mer enfin l on sait
maintenant que l'âme est rôti la mère de
l'enfant autiste n'a aucune
responsabilité dans l'autisme de son
enfant et c'est très difficile parce
qu'en france on est encore sous cette
influence là il y à des enjeux
qui nous dépasse avec des enjeux de
pouvoir qui sont catastrophiques pour
une importance du travail de votre
association notamment sur le terrain
vous avez développé le parcours hymne
ligne aussi les sedin donc là là en fait
aujourd'hui nous avons un bon enfant qui
accueille les enfants de donc de l'âge
de 3 ans à 20 ans et un pôle adulte qui
avait accueilli les enfants donc de
jeunes adultes à l'eau d'adultes
autistes vieillissant et nous sommes
même en train de faim nous attendons là
nous sommes en projet pour un pur pour
un truc une structure médicalisée pour
les adultes autistes vieillissant donc
la structure existe mais le foyer va
devenir médicalisé pour accompagner les
adultes qui ont 40 ans et plus et qui
comme tous les adultes vieillissent avec
tous les problèmes qui sont liés au fait
prendre de l'âge donc logiquement de
notre association aujourd'hui on devrait
pouvoir être accompagnée depuis l'âge de
3 ans jusqu'à la fin de vie le problème
évidemment c'est que nous n'avons pas de
place pour tout le monde mais nous ne
pouvons pas répondre à tout le monde
un moyen également un ailleurs
effectivement je parlais tout à l'heure
des dons en des contributeurs s'ils
veulent se manifester via notamment des
coordonnées qui vont s'afficher c'est
les coordonnées de l'association autisme
france et dont dépend autisme yvelines
que vous menez pour le département juste
pour conclure très rapidement on va voir
une photo une photo d'une fresque une
fresque tout en bleu puisque le bleu
c'est la couleur de ralliement autour de
cette cause de l'autisme au est éprise
réaliser cette fresque bardon alors elle
a été réalisée par les enfants et les
professionnels de l'ime notre école de
autisme en yvelines
c'est à l'occasion de la journée bleue
jeudi 2 avril journée de sensibilisation
mondiale à l'autisme et
c'est formidable parce qu'ils ont tous
mis leurs mains en couleur bleue et ses
enfants attendent beaucoup de la société
attendent beaucoup de nous associations
professionnelles c'est pour eux que nous
travaillons est essentielle il est
essentiel pour eux que la france se
mobilise et que la france sorte de de
son protard et puis j'ai envie de dire
que c'est essentiel aussi pour les
professionnels il faut que les
professionnels soient soutenus et
reconnus
et puis je voudrais aussi faire un petit
signe à toutes les fratries les frères
et soeurs qui dont on ne parle pas
souvent mais qui souffre beaucoup de la
situation très souvent il en est mondial
je le disais c'est aujourd'hui vous vous
l'avez entendu le gouvernement qui n'a
pas encore présenté elles sont plombées
les associations sur le terrain qui
continuent leur travail merci à toutes
les deux d'être venu à l'occasion de
cette journée on parle d'éducation à
présent dans le 7,8 après les rythmes
scolaires en début d'édition se penche
sur la carte scolaire 2013 qui se
dessine dans les yvelines 800 élèves
supplémentaires sont attendus à la
rentrée 2013 66 ouvertures de classe 49
fermeture le point complet sur notre
secteur
la carte scolaire pour la rentrée 2013
se dessine le département se dote de 74
postes supplémentaires dans le premier
degré maternelle et primaire et les
yvelines voit le nombre des élèves
progresser avec une hausse attendue de
800 écoliers 66 ouvertures de classes
envisagées dans le département sur notre
secteur à pau darcis coignières
elancourt guyancourt la verrière
maurepas montigny le bretonneux plaisir
saint cyr l'école et trappe a contrario
dans le projet de carte scolaire
dévoilée par l'inspection académique
quarante neuf fermetures de classes sont
envisagées à elancourt guyancourt les
clayes-sous-bois magny les hameaux
maurepas montigny le bretonneux trappe
et voisins le bretonneux
d'autre part un accueil spécifique de
nouveaux élèves de moins de 3 ans est
prévu dans 11 écoles dont à maurepas et
trois écoles concernées à trappes ces
mesures seront soumises à l'avis du
conseil départemental de l'éducation
nationale qui suivraient
ira à la mi avril